[Music]
let's go out to leslie in arlington
what's up leslie
hey dr john how are you
good it's been a heck of a show so far
how are you i'm i'm i'm good i think i i
took that deep breath just as you did
wow yeah man so how can i help what's up
well um i am calling to get a little bit
of advice from you on navigating the
crazy world of youth sports um recently
i had my first experience exactly yeah
yeah i basically had my eye was blown
off my face whenever i had this
experience and then started talking to
all the different parents that are
navigating this journey as i am
um recently i had my eight-year-old try
out for a baseball team nothing crazy
you know um and he did well he
he does well with sports you know we
have him in all kinds of sports nothing
you know nothing crazy just recognizing
stuff
he's eight he's a little eight-year-old
boy and um so we ended up tried out for
this team and i ended up getting
this long email back from the coach
and he was telling me how talented my
son was and how
you know he did really really well and
then it started taking a different kind
of turn and as i'm reading through it
i'm like wait a second the coach is
talking about um
how there's this challenge with uniforms
and
there's this travel team that he's part
of and that they have decided at the end
that because they wouldn't be able to
get the uniforms back in time
for the tournament that he had you know
had tried out for to get this team to
play in
um
the coach said we'll have to go with all
of the travel team players that already
have the uniforms and i'm like what
what what is this um i read a couple
times i'm like wow so you know we really
are selecting
you know
you know these young kids based off of
uniforms you know versus talent and it
really it just took me a few steps back
like wow wow wow wow these are
eight-year-olds um
and i really kind of i talked to a bunch
of parents and i'm like is this is this
normal is this like a one-off thing you
know did i just have really bad
experience
and
i was blown away by the feedback because
it seems like everybody that has
children that are interested in sports
are kind of navigating the same path
where you either you know play in one
type of rec league or you invest
thousands of dollars and to travel
whatever travel team you want to put
that kid in and it kind of locks them in
for only playing that sport because the
requirements are so intense and
i'm in the medical field so i have a bit
of a background on like you know
development and everything like that and
i'm like what are we doing to our kids
like
why are we all standing by and and not
like waving our hands and saying enough
is enough this is insane yes so i made a
decision you know cause i'm like okay i
feel crappy either way whether i respond
back to this coach or not so i decided
you know what i just i feel like i need
to say something so i wrote back and
just said you know
i'm really challenged with understanding
the philosophy behind your decision
making because
they're eight-year-old kids you know
whoever's the best tell me my kid isn't
good enough that's fine
that's a great lesson to teach him you
know you got to work hard for the things
you want
you know and
what ended up happening and wrote it
sent it i got an even longer email back
really you know him discussing with me
in depth how challenging this decision
is about uniforms i mean it went on and
on and on
and he was upset that i would question
his ethics with coaching leslie
leslie
do you want this man having influence
over your child
oh absolutely not no and that's the
thing it's like walk away yeah i mean
walk away absolutely walk away totally
well but it kind of brought me up to the
point of you know i'm one of many people
that are out there that are in a
situation where
our kids you know they're eight we're
going to be walking this path for quite
some time and i knew we you know
everybody's going to at some point of
course but it ate it really took me back
like these are just little guys
and really looking at your advice on how
to really more so communicate this to
your kids you know you want to be
truthful but you don't want to give them
too much information you know whatever
is appropriate
you know and you know life's not fair
and that's a lesson to teach them for
sure
but um what are your thoughts on how
we get through this um
yeah so i got i got a lot of thoughts on
this um my thoughts were originally
informed by you know you know i worked
at colleges forever and i would always
i was a i was an athlete and so i would
always end up hanging out with the
athletes hanging out with um not so much
athletes as much as coaches were my
friends and the trainers were my friends
and it started about a decade ago when
my training friends
friends who were trainers at college
athletic trainers
were telling me that they were starting
to see young people come through
with joint use injuries seen in the
elderly
from over-specialization
and year-round sporting practices
and a lack of unstructured play in
multiple sports
and then that just so that was just a
thing in my head like
what what do you mean it's like oh kids
don't play
baseball and then they all play soccer
then they all play basketball and then
they get to middle school and they play
football too and then they run track
no at age six they play baseball and
then they get a hitting coach and a
pitching coach and they make the select
team and it plays in fall and then in
spring and there's a summer league
and you're already specializing as a
shortstop at age seven right
yeah and so
that was number one that was the madness
call number one what are we doing why
and then
um number two was the insane
rise in childhood anxiety and depression
and then
i started seeing the rise in adult
anxiety and depression
and then as i dug into the literature on
the kids i realized the kids are simply
responding to their environments and the
environments are created by the adults
and then i had my own son
and
he's a great athlete he's a phenomenal
athlete and to him he's just kind of a
go with the flow guy he's really good
and it i remember my first um game that
i went to the coach we had the first
coach was phenomenal magnificent human
being
but i remember the first game and i
remember thinking
i have to decide now if i'm going to get
in a fist fight or not because i'm not
going to let that dad talk to those kids
that way on the as a dad on the other
team
and i knew if i go say something to that
hothead i'm going to end up in a
physical altercation and i was having to
make that decision and it was a
field of six-year-olds or five-year-olds
or whatever it was
and
so
you said it best
it's the parents fault
full stop that we've allowed this to get
this way
it's abusive and i use that word
intentionally and i had somebody email
me and say i overuse that word i don't
we're torturing our children
by forcing them to live vicariously
through our
either achieved or failed athletic
adventures and somehow parents have
come to put our self-esteem
like there's some sort of checklist that
if our kids makes good grades and
they're good at sports that that's
somehow a performance car scorecard for
us as parents right
and so we've created this world
and so i go loop back to to answer your
question i loop back to how do you tell
your kids
you could i don't think it's
developmentally appropriate you could
tell your kid
well you just found out
you may not get the job not because you
weren't the most talented but because
somebody knew somebody that's just the
way that works or because they had a
nicer suit on in the interview
that is how the world works by the way
and that could very much happen i don't
know that an eight-year-old is gonna get
anything other than bitter and anxious
about that so i don't know that i would
tell them that
what i would say is this i have preached
to my kids since they were little i've
got one job on the planet
and i can say it right now to both of
them what's my one job and my kit my son
rolls his eyes and he's like to keep me
safe and my daughter won't even say it
anymore she just looks at the ground
because she's like she's just annoyed by
it
and that phrase my job is to keep you
safe
includes intellectually psychologically
spiritually and and physically
and so when my kids say hey why won't
you give us a smartphone
we're nine and everyone else in the
classroom has a smartphone at nine
i'll say what's my one job
to keep you safe
and when i tell my son hey we're not
playing in this league which i've done
we're not i'm not going to do this
league
not because i don't want to drive you
around not because i can't afford it
it's but it's because i don't want you
thinking
that the end result here is in any way
shaping you in a positive direction
because it's not
i do think playing sports is really
important and one of the rules is when
our kids have to do a thing they have to
play something
whether it's jiu jitsu whether it's
soccer whether it's it's wreck baseball
whether my son's in the cro he's a track
and cross-country guru
he's really good at that so you got to
do something you got to do something
physical and you got to do something as
part of a team that's that's important i
think the evidence would bear that out
i am intentionally opting out
of any sort of pre-professional training
until my kid is a junior senior in high
school then we will start having hard
conversations about what's next until
then it is play first and when they ask
why can't i be on this and why can't i
do that
my job is to keep you safe and i don't
want you around the mess the toxic
nonsensical idiotic parents
i'm not going to use that language by
the way that was between me and you that
was between me
no no check check check you you nailed
it
but but i think i think telling my
eight-year-old you didn't make the team
they had a bunch of different criteria
that wasn't just about who's the better
baseball player well what do you mean
they had all kinds of things about
uniforms and other things
and
i'm opting for you to not play in that
league
we're going to go play baseball here
or this summer we're taking the summer
off
yeah
and that's ultimately you know sorry for
the long rambling you know things no
it's good you're absolutely right it is
it's like yeah we're not going to do
that we're going to a different one
because that i would you know you're not
going to be influencing my child the
most precious gift
um but it you're absolutely right it's
absolutely bananas to see
how
even for me like how these kids identity
is being tied to their performance
whether it's but they're getting that
from us
yeah absolutely yeah and i don't want my
kid you don't want you know what my
eight-year-old to do have fun
yeah i want him to learn hey if if you
strike out it costs your team i think
that's a good lesson i don't have any
problem with that i think it's great
i want him to know hey if you stay up
till 2 a.m at a sleepover party and have
nothing but donuts and m m's and you
strike out four times the next day i
want i wanted to begin to to connect
right your behavior yesterday impacted
your whole team today that's a good
lesson
yeah but i want him to have fun
yeah i want my kid to play he's got the
rest of his life to have the world tell
him that he sucks at everything that
he's not good enough
it it reminds me of this
um and i may have mentioned this on the
show they're back in the early ufc days
in the in the um the valley tudo days
way back in the day my favorite fighters
in the world came out of a gym out of
brazil it was vandaly silva and shogun
hua and all these guys they were
incredible but here's how they trained
they just got in fist fights every day
and they knocked each other unconscious
that was how they trained
and now you fast forward 30 years later
and they did that because if you can get
through our practices like a fight with
another
professional will be nothing it'll be
nothing
right until they started showing up
several years later with
um
brain injuries and repeated knee and
elbow and hand injuries
and hip injuries and what they've now
realized is they they save heavy hard
sparring
for rare times and everybody's padded up
to the max because we're only going to
go full tilt when we're getting paid for
it in a ring
and so i tell you to say i hear the
argument my kid needs to toughen up and
he needs to learn the world will be glad
to beat your kid up
you doing that when he's 8 9 10 11 14 is
nonsense
let your kid run around in the street
with a stick and a ball and some mud let
your kid go to the pool let your kid and
save the gas money by the way gas is
expensive right now
i would love dude i would love to see
just a parents rise up across the
country it would take one facebook post
all travel sports are canceled this
summer we're not doing it we're not
going to
hundred dollars to prop up um a bunch of
adult egos we're not
and i by the way i've got no
trouble with with uh travel ball a
little league world series is great i
think this stuff is good when the
coaches are great the coaches are
phenomenal we've had some remarkable
coaches
remarkable dick coach david amazing guy
goes charlie coach those guys are so
great
and we've got some other ones that just
can't get it can't parents and whatever
man
all let's say
let your kids play
keep them safe psychologically
emotionally spiritually physically best
you can you gotta let them hurt you
gotta let them fall down let's don't i
mean
i don't mean i don't mean bubble wrap
them
and don't let them have any scars that's
not that's not right
they gotta take their lumps
but they can't prop up our fragile adult
egos
leslie your kid's lucky to have you get
him out of that nonsense and let him go
play he's only eight